- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn how to get great.
Over to you, Dean Graziosi.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- The biggest lie we've ever been told
is to work on our weaknesses.
Biggest BS in the world.
The hell with your weaknesses,
I was in special reading til 12th Grade,
I couldn't spell for sh--.
Right now, my computer
if it could talk to me,
I try to type words and send an email
and I'll go through three
different variations.
It can't even find the word.
It's like give up bro, use a simpler word.
You just don't have the
vocabulary and I know that.
But I still have multiple
New York Times bestsellers.
I've been touched a lot,
been able to touch the
lives of millions of people
because here's the secret:
get great at what you're already good at
and pay people to do the
sh-- that you suck at.
(crowd cheering)
Does that make sense?
Get great at what you're good at.
I'm going to give you one example.
Ned Hallowell.
Oprah in America considers him
the number one ADD
specialist in the world.
Attention Deficit Disorder.
I said to him one day,
we became good friends,
I said, "How do you cure so many kids?"
"Get 'em off Ritalin and
get 'em off medication."
He said "Simple."
He said "I find out what
happens as Johhny's in class.
"He's trying to read a book.
"His teacher says, "You
sit there and read that
"and you can't get up until you're done."
"He freaks out, runs around,
now he's got ADHD, he's hyper."
He said, "What we do, and
then they medicate him."
He goes, "What I do is I
find what Johnny's good at.
"Maybe he's good at math, gym, soccer
"and we get his team around
him, his family around him,
"and we help him get great
at what he's good at.
"His confidence goes up
"and Johnny reads the book on his own."
- I don't know why we're taught
to focus on our weaknesses so much.
The world belongs to the
people who are experts
at what they do and to
provide insane value,
not to the person who is
mediocre at everything.
This a great story about
the bunny that forgot to hop
and I forget who initially told it,
but there's this bunny
who's going to school
and he's learning to hop
and he's learning to swim.
He gets an A on his hopping but
he's failing in his swimming
and so his parents start
freaking out and say,
"Okay, we got to take you to swim lessons.
"You got to get better at swimming.
"You got to practice,
you got to hustle harder.
"We're going to take
you to private lessons.
"We're going to take you out to school
"where you're going to learn,
learn, learn about how to swim."
And slowly, slowly, slowly
he gets better to swim
and he went from being
an F student in swimming
to a C student in swimming.
But because he spent so much time
being a C student at swimming
and bridging that gap,
he also falls from being
an A student in hopping
to be a C student at hopping.
And kind of along the way,
he forgets how to hop.
And that's what a bunny
is supposed to do is hop.
And so the world will tell you
to focus on your weaknesses.
The world will tell you all
the things that you suck at
and that you need to get better at.
Understand that for you to
have the impact that you want,
to make the money that you want,
or to reach the people that you want,
to build the business that you want,
the best way to do it is to
not focus on your weaknesses.
It's to find the things
that you are great at.
Find the thing that you can be
one of the best in the world at.
You may not have that talent yet,
but you have the ability
to be one of the greatest
in the world at doing
X, what is that thing?
Focus as much time on
that thing as possible
and then as you build and
grow, surround yourself
with the people who
complement your weaknesses
'cause they love doing
the things that you hate.
That's how successful teams are built.
That's how successful
businesses are built.
Stop focusing on your weaknesses.
So the question today is I'm curious,
"What was the biggest
weakness that you gave up,
"that people said you needed to focus on,
"but you felt like I'm not
going to do this anymore.
"I have more important, bigger things,
"that I'm more talented at,
that I'm going to go out
"and crush instead.
"What was that biggest
weakness that you gave up
"and handed to somebody else?"
Leave it down in the comments below,
really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Alejandro Rivas.
Alejandro, thank you
so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "Your One Word."
It really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(clacking)
- You need to bet on your strengths
and don't give a f--
about what you suck at.
Way too many people in this room
are going to spend the next
30, 40 years of their lives
trying to check the boxes of the things
that they're not as good
at and that you're going to
waste a f-- load of time and lose.
I highly recommend auditing yourself
or if you have no f-- empathy or EQ
or self-awareness, then
find somebody in your family
or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are.
And once you believe
that, either for yourself
or someone else told you, go directly,
all chips all into that
because that is the only
possible way, in my opinion
watching from the outside,
that is, let me rephrase.
That is a very highly,
likely way of over-indexing
because the truth is, if
you want to be an anomaly,
you've got to act like one.
And so, that's it, that's what I got,
so thanks for having me.
- You need to know what
your unique strengths are
and be willing to delegate them.
So I would say that the
question of whether you should
take a skill, learn it yourself,
delegate it to someone else
or hire a new team
member, are determined by
having a very accurate self-assessment,
an assessment of your team skills,
not only at what you can do,
but what you should be doing.
That's very important, so
if you are a startup CEO
or founder, and you have a
team of say two to 10 people,
as soon as you have funds to hire,
you should not be focused on
the things that you are bad at.
Sounds very, very intuitive, but it's not
because you might have enough
time to do those things,
but the question is do you
have the attention to dedicate
to those things so they're
not an interruption?
Especially if you're
a venture-back startup
and you're competing
against other companies
that also have a lot of funding.
The game and the race goes to the swift
so you have to have a lot of velocity.
- Knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and knowing what you enjoy doing.
If you look at it as a
job, you've already lost.
It's not going to be your passion
and you're going to count the hours.
If you look at it as
something you love to do
and you know what your strengths are,
then you can leverage those strengths
in your business and in helping others
and once you recognize your weaknesses,
then you can work with
people that complement you.
I mean, every one of my businesses,
I've had a partner who's
very anal (laughing).
Martin Woodall, Todd Wagner, I
mean, incredibly anal people,
perfectionists, because I'm a slob.
I'm a big picture, think about
what's around the corner,
how's technology going to
change things, how can I change,
you know, this industry, and you know,
making sure that there's somebody there
to dot the I's, cross the T's and keep me
in the baselines and
recognizing my weaknesses
is just as important as
recognizing my strengths
and my core competencies and
having the passion to do 'em.